this is what pizza looks like look at
this what happened like this is not the
Mona Lisa like this is the Renaissance
period yeah and not abstract art movie
in Pisa together we've had to have had
pizza together not often enough right
yeah we just had it like two days ago
correct the basis of our friendship is
mostly eaten that's true yeah that's
pretty easy I think okay yeah let's see
how easy it is all right welcome to we
don't know what we're doing how do you
measure an ounce it's more like sugar
than salt do you have to probably make
it into a ball that's it's it's all
white second yeah wonderful I can't wait
to eat that now we just let it sit
oh god this feels really gross this is a
terrible on the ground and we won't have
to eat that yes yes see it's fine it's
bright hold the two of us together make
one competent you can get bad side I'll
go to this side yeah don't roll it out
too much because we're gonna bring it
over it's a pan over you're gonna push
it it's happy it's a happy pizza half a
pizza like you have a great style going
why don't you wild with it look at that
yeah okay we're done we're done now
let's put this on up oh shoot how are
you gonna move it fit under there scoop
it in hey up oh this is going I swear
it's gonna work there we go yeah that's
how you make a pizza
oh and let's super Joey look at that
that kind of looks like a pizza squished
out one that's funny it's very light
airy I like thin crust crispy pizzas and
this is like here it's like super thick
I'm I will take responsibility for that
yeah this is more like the idea of pizza
than it is yeah
sausage it looks like it's like the
caramelized onions your honor you upped
your game that's what Peter supposed to
taste like but cooking in general I
think I'm good now forever
I mean I'm clearly not following any
plan with my cheese that's kind of the
way you are with your life oh thanks mom